pandemic switching up some annual
thanksgiving traditions and
for many that meant heading to one place
about 25 minutes from the strip
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
visits red rock canyon where visitors
stopped
before those big meals tonight
a steady amount of people coming to the
red rock canyon dedication overlooked
this thanksgiving
they're here braving the wind and chill
to take pictures
and enjoy the scenery it's really cool
but it's really nice to
feel fresh air you know the scenic
destination offering some a temporary
escape from the pandemic situation
various people parked and either hiked
biked or
gazed at the landscape for some coming
to the national conservation area is a
first time experience
while others consider it a holiday
tradition the thanksgiving weekend
remains the busiest time of year for red
rock canyon
kobe 19 did not seem to change that so
volunteers like morgan hawkins came out
to help direct
traffic so there were over almost like a
thousand reservations made for just
today
and they're expecting even more for this
weekend so it was really busy
the bureau of land management started
requiring reservations earlier this
month
it aims to help address capacity issues
we've been making reservations like the
night before
for each day we go into the park anyone
who wants to visit the 13-mile red rock
canyon scenic loop must make a
reservation
you can do that online reporting from
red rock canyon kristen drummond 8 news
now